hello everyone I suppose we can start
I'm Susanna Sakawa I'm a developer
advocate at jetbrains
and today I'm going to talk about
Courtland cortines
I can hardly see you but probably it
will work sister people on the first row
like and I can see you and I will be
able to see where they are confused or
not because this topic is kind of a
complicated one but I hope to share the
power that this kind of old new approach
brings calling Hortense is a concept
that is available already so no sorry
not column but coroutine as a concept is
available for a lot of decades and at
first it was used to model a synchronous
programming even before threads were
invented and for instance the sharp I
think of it is feature that works that
uses coroutines under the hood in the
underlying implementation but you as a
developer you only use a sink and a
weight functionality there are proteins
and channels in go that are quite
popular and in Cortland with some
differences it's basically the same idea
the same concept and there are many more
languages and approaches that also I
interested in adopting the same pattern
so after hearing about Kali gorgeous you
will not only learn about hopefully not
only learn about coffee qualities but
about coroutines in general and that is
one of my goals who is here c-sharp
developers
ok so my guess was correct because I
kind of assumed that I will do a talk
for people who already know what is a
sinker weight because in the Java world
there is no similar concept and we need
to start from scratch and explain how it
works I will briefly explain but I want
to go deep into detail here in Cortland
you can use the same a sink and a weight
as in c-sharp ok it looks a bit
in c-sharp you use a sink and a weight
and I think into it our language
keyboards in courtly
I think underweight are irregular
functions so it looks a bit differently
you can specify ty for purchase image
function and it will return you the
deferred object which is similar to
tasks so we have another name for tasks
in court and deferred but the concept is
is the same it's very similar
interesting thing here is that I think
in the wait in c-sharp our language
keywords in Kotlin they are just
functions defined in the standard
library and the ability to define them
as functions as many more functions that
library or regular that will behave in
this way is based on the code or the
concept of cortines and together today
we are going to discuss how exactly it
works and water qualities my agenda for
today talk is at first I want to discuss
suspend functions so that is something
to you that Kotlin brings to the picture
that is you you will write the code in a
bit different manner in cosmo rather
than just using cosmetic in so sharp
then i want to cover what i want to
explain what is the crew team then we
are going to discuss your actual
concurrency that is another important
thing that comes to the world with
causing corrosion support and i want to
add talking about Charles so let's start
and let's first discuss this but suspend
functions how to write code with the
suspect function so encoding again it's
a bit differently let's start with
example let's imagine we have simple
consecutive logic and let's imagine that
our login method needs to do some
errands the authentication does need to
go to a service so it might be time
consuming and we would like to avoid
here blocking the threat while calling
this method let's imagine that load goes
to I don't know remote database that's
another
probably blocking method that might
block the thread that is time-consuming
and both these methods will just await
the result for most of the time and just
writing this code straightforwardly in a
consequent fashion is that good because
we are blocking the thread we use we
waste resources this thread just ways
for most of the time we would like to
avoid it and if we its main UI thread
it's even worse because our user is
booked this is the general story that
you probably listen when you are
listening to talk about a sink of a 10 C
sharp and indeed C sharp with a sink of
weight brings the solution to this and
say okay now you extract your function
that goes to service into something
returning a task in corteguay case it
will be deferred and then you start this
function will start our these requests
are synchronously and then here you will
need to call a weight to use a way to
await for this result this solution
doesn't block underlying thread it is
fine ice and everything works great in
Cortland again you can use this similar
approach you can write the code in very
similar fashion task is replaced with
deferred you call a sync you call I
think as a function and the weight is
also as a function available on this
deferred object it's not a language
concern however in Cortland you can also
do better than this and instead of
defining a function that returns a
future a deferred or responding to task
in c-sharp you can mark this function
with a suspend modifier say meaning that
this function can somehow suspend under
the hood this this function can probe
will most probably wait for something
and it might be suspended
while running this code this works very
similar to how I think a wet work
because this in a sink weight case a
weight also marks at the point when the
computation might be suspended so
suspend function is a function that can
be suspended in the case of c-sharp we
have explicitly suspension points marked
with a weight if you think about it that
the same idea you use a weight somewhere
when your function in this case show
user in for function might be suspended
waiting until the result is ready and in
Kotlin it works in the same way with the
only difference that now any function
any suspend function call is a marker
off of this function that can be
suspended not only a weight I think in
the weight can be used in this way but
any fraction can be marked as suspended
and as a result you no longer need to
put a way to all the places where you're
where in your code you need to avoid for
the result where where there is some
suspension point the code now the
resulting code in coding case looks just
the same as the one before the wine and
the first slide when we had when we
wrote everything in a blocking manner
you're wrong but looking manner IntelliJ
highlights all the points where the
fraction might be suspended so here this
side you see this broken errors and this
errors are markers in IDE showing that
here you call suspend function here your
computation might be suspended my might
be broken there is a question where it's
possible to call as a span factor so in
Cortland anyone can't define a suspend
function
the question is okay where can we call
them and if you try to to call it from a
regular function like Josh right
function test and call our suspend
function from this test then you'll see
the compiler error that suspend function
show user should be called only from a
curtain or another saucepan function and
that brings us to the concepts to the
concept of coroutines saying that this
suspend function can be called only
inside the core routine or another
suspend function and now I'm going to
move to the concept of curtains before
we move on I want to probably highlight
a bit more why we decided why in Kotlin
it was decided this way so that use any
suspend function as a marker instead of
using classical a sink a weight approach
in at first instance our pew need to put
this weight markers all the time but
more importantly in c-sharp when you
call when you just call a function that
calls that starts some computation a
synchronously without calling a weight
then you will start the computation in
erm okay I'm sorry
I will just yes this slide you will just
remember that Slifer this and so why not
why not why curtain doesn't use a weight
keyword similar to what we have in
c-sharp in c-sharp if you start if you
just write the function that throws that
stress I think honors computation
concurrently by default that that will
be like concurrent version and to make
it sequential you will need to
explicitly call
a wait on this function and cortland
kind of changes this default now if you
just call the suspend function that just
means okay this function somehow can be
suspended under the hood and to make it
concurrent to start your your
computation concurrently you will need
to use explicit syntax for this so the
idea is to to modify this default choice
of how to write the code and to make all
the concurrency explicit while there
while at the same time making this
mechanism or suspension in built-in in
the language while using the suspend
functions any questions so far you can
ask questions during the talk yes
yeah how do how do how do it it's
possible to start tasks concurrently
yes multiple curses day let's let's move
on then and I will show this example so
yes that's possible so now we are going
to talk about coroutines what is the
concept of quarantine and how and how
basically to start several computations
are synchronous second the same way
there are short answer is very similar
to to what you used to and that's
possible so what is a karate karate is a
computation that can be suspended what
does it mean we start a computation in
the threat according and then at some
point when it needs to wait for Network
result when it needs to wait for some
for for some result of its request it
can be suspended that means that we can
put it off the threat storage in memory
and then restored there this I think
wait in C sharp works in the same way
under the hood because the it's also
implemented by a question so that's very
very generic way to explain how all crew
teams work and while our work routine is
suspended so this computation that waits
for our network result the thread is
free to be occupied with other tasks and
activities so we can start some other
computations here while our coding is
waiting for the result and when the
result is coming then this crew team can
be restored to the main thread how to
create a crew team and how to start
for instance this a synchronous
computation well already know that
because we see this a sync board I think
is one of so called coding builders they
are just library functions again a sink
is one of the library functions but
there are more so free so there is
another one launch mentions in the
previous talk I will for simplicity I
will just use a sink in this talk so
there are different library functions
that can
charge computations in a different
manner I think starts a new computation
synchronously you can use our unblocking
which is a common entry point in this
way it starts a new cube relation either
in the blocking minor it often is used
in main functions and tests but when you
write code you most commonly will use a
sink and other library functions
interestingly here is that different
libraries can define their own routine
builders so because Croton builders is
just a pattern that should be fooled
when you write code in Kotlin it's
possible to define Croton builders that
are specific to the library to some use
case to some specific case in the
library let's look at how very simple or
load classical load image exam example
works this one uses a single weight and
again I would say that it's very similar
to how it works in c-sharp and then
we'll we'll see how it how it works with
general suspend function but it explains
this mechanism mechanism of suspension
equality so this example we have load
image a sinc function that calls our
sink which starts and you a synchronous
computation a sink creates a new crew
teen and because I think I think is
defined this way it starts new
computation a synchronously I will mark
that okay we probably will start it on a
different thread and I will mark this
load image a sink coroutine with this a
green car then we call process image
inside process image where first load
images load images sync is called and
then a weight is called a weight is a
suspension point and a weight function
is just defined as a suspend function in
kata library so that what I was talking
about you that a weight and a sink
adjust library functions in contact they
are not key
and the power is that similar concept
similar constructs similar library
functions might be defined and added to
libraries a way to define as a spent
function and that means that a weight is
that a weight actually can suspend the
Croteam in this case we already started
our load image our sync on thread
now when the code continues its
execution here I just extracted the
result of low temperature I think to a
variable in order to better understand
what's going on we straw the reference
to this computation in a deferred
variable in case of c-sharp
it's stored just in a task variable and
then when we call a weight it is the
marker that says this at this point the
computation should average for something
and unless the result is already
available
the main capitation must be suspended so
if our image was cashed and the result
was returned immediately then a weight
is not doesn't need to suspend the
computation it just can continue to
execution in our case the image is
loading so a weight suspends the process
image computation that meanwhile a ways
for the result so here now process image
computation is suspended and the first
thread is free to be occupied with other
tasks and activities when load image
loads the image and returns the result
then this process image coroutine can be
returned to the thread can be so called
resumed and can continue its execution
so that's how general mechanism of
suspending the current works again this
picture also describes how it works in
c-sharp in cotan case because every
suspend function might be at the point
where the crew teen is suspended the
crew team can be suspended for instance
several times so in case of show user we
have this our show user function and it
does two network requests that but
surely might be just might await for the
result and if they're implemented in the
correct fashion if they use the
suspension mechanism then that means
that this corrosion can be suspended
twice the first time when we call login
and it waits for some result
second time when we call load and again
it waits for the result when I talk when
I'm talking that here in this example
coroutine will be suspended twice
you can ask which coating which routine
get suspended when as a span function is
called as their answer is very similar
the one simple the one that just
contains this suspend function in our
application we need to call show user
from I've told you either suspend
function or an oil crew team let's say
we call this show user from some
coroutine started with a sink and when
I'm telling you that show user that this
cartoon will be suspended when show user
ways for for something that means that
this routine created by a sink the
parent crew team the outer core team
will be suspended you can define suspend
functions that call different suspend
function so you just need to mark these
all these functions as suspend so in
Kotla there are like two worlds regular
functions and suspend functions and
suspend functions mean that they are
special functions that should be called
in on the side coroutines
and they mark that in this case the crew
team can be suspended and their call
stack of your suspend functions might be
different like as deep as you need so
for instance here we first start
co-routine with calling a sink then we
call show user show user inside this
function calls another
spen functions like load user then at
some point it needs to call either wait
or another library function that in its
turn uses the language primitive that
actually says that okay this is the
point when corrosion is suspended so at
the language level we have suspend
corrosion function which will actually
suspend a routine but as an application
developer you will you can defer you
will probably never use it you use
library functions like a weight and
other different libraries for instance
you can use library that allows you to
the from Network requests in the suspend
function and so on or to connect to data
bases in the suspend function a fashion
is own you use suspend routine if you
elaborate author or you want to add to
write a wrapper to your library in this
case you can write this wrapper too
because if you have a library that
doesn't support suspend this is this
approach on the futures or all callbacks
in this case you can write wrappers and
tries the service you will use a special
template and you suspend crotons but in
general case you only you're living this
application lever as an application
developer and you can define your
suspend functions which call another
suspend fractions which under the hood
will call a weight or other library
functions and that turns out to be
really convenient because now you can
you don't need to put all their waists
everywhere but you can just keep in mind
that okay this is the function that
might be suspended this at some point
and you can structure your code
accordingly which results in a and
really a better structure event when the
core routine is suspended the whole
object of karate is stored on the heap
so in this case we have this call stack
and it represents the core routine the
protein is throat using called
object and when the Cortina suspect
suspended this object is just short in
memory and it saves the call stack
together with all the captured variables
along the way
so the grooty stores all the information
to be able to resume it that how it
works under the hood and when here is a
resume protein the cost records are
stored and the coroutine continues its
execution
you can ask here on which thread does
the crew teen start and resume and the
answer is that you specify that when you
create a code so you can use some
default parameters but you can provide
explicit parameters for instance you you
can decide that I won't run this go
routine on a thread pool organs and
decide I want to run this routine or the
men who I thread and you just specified
explicitly in your application or you
can use some default parameter for vocal
routines in a give all of the proteins
in the given scope here I say run your
origin routine on the thread however
more correct would be would be say
schedule your resumed protein on a given
thread because obviously if you resume
your computation and it should run on
the main UI thread
if this man who I throw it is busy and
this this time this routine will be just
here dude no Tron immediately and it
will be run when the thread gets free
the same with the thread pool if all the
threads in the thread pool are busy then
it should wait a bit more until
something is it's free and there are
other dispatcher there are other
dispatchers that for instance can add
motorized dynamically if if everything
else if every every one is a good bite
but here interesting thing also is that
you can define your own dispatchers you
can create your own way specify how to
how to schedule how to run desk routines
but for majority of the cases the
default ones are L
and work quite well coroutines can't be
nested inside one another so it's very
easy to start a crew teen inside another
Co routine and you can ask here is there
any relationship between parent and
child crew team as their answer is yes
and it turns out us to talk about
structured concurrency everything that
I've told before especially of how the
suspension mechanism works this is known
for decades right now and this is
already implemented in many languages in
Kotlin new approach is using the suspend
function but some may argue that it
mostly syntactic think however really
convenient
this structure concurrency is something
new it's also can be applied note and
can be promoted not only in Courtley
there are some libraries they try to
implement it for instance for Python but
in Cortland it R is something that is
built-in and interestingly at first
Cortland didn't have structural
concurrency so we have the routines for
some time was a war available in
experimental state for quite a long time
for several months or even a year and
during this time it was found out that
just keeping the structure the
relationship between different routines
by hand is quite complicated and it can
be done automatically by the compiler so
let's discuss what structured structure
concurrency is and how it works let's
start with an example let's say we have
two asynchronous coroutines
so you can easily start computations as
your own asleep for this you still use a
single weight so suspend suspend
functions really great when you when you
don't have concurrency you just want
something to be done a synchronous and
wait for the result for concurrent cases
I think a wage are all great in this
case
we have there overlay function that
probably superior zooming is just we'll
do some algorithmic logic of relating to
images and we have this suspend launch
and a really function that at further
that tries to start to load two images
concurrently and at the end it will just
parse this loaded images Torvill a
function it just works great lot of
relay will be suspended until the result
is right Israeli so that is okay example
especially if everything works well
however what happens if the exception is
thrown inside one of the child care
routines during an image load the
problem with this approach unless you do
something special is that the second
coroutine will leak it will just
continue to load the image
no one will cancel it again we have the
green routine that fails then exception
let's imagine exception is thrown a
weight will just throw this exception
further and their load and overlay
coroutine will catch this exception it
doesn't handle it in any way so it will
just sort of throw it and it will fail
as well however in this case no one does
anything specifically with a second
started co-routine and it just continues
its execution it and no one is
interested in this result but it
continues to load the image and this is
a problem this problem might be somehow
dressed by the framework or the or
application developer you can manually
straw the references to all their
started activities keep these references
and do something accordingly when
something goes wrong coding now provides
the built-in solution to this problem by
introducing local scope you just fix
this problem
well the parent where the child routine
leaks or fails sorry then the parent
scope catches this exception and
automatically cancels all the child
routines and then fails itself so we
have the same as before with this
difference that now we don't have the
problem the second routine is canceled
coroutine scopes are built-in in this
curtain framework curtain library and
curtain scope
waits for completion of all children
routines and also it cancels all child
crew teens if something went wrong and
that this functionality is built-in in
the language support and it's not only
built-in it's enforced so in my some of
my examples I didn't use the syntax to
simplify things
however in code lane in real code mean
you can't start a new computation
anywhere you need to always provide a
scope in which scope you start new
coding a sync function under the hood is
defined as an extension function on
co-routine scope so just once resolve if
you just try to call a sync everywhere
you always need to start coroutines
inside
a new scope you can start it explicitly
inside coding scope you can start it in
global scope and this a global scope
syntax is something that so at first in
the first design all the cruelties first
started in the global scope and at some
point it was clear that it works better
with the structural ratio all the coding
builders were rewritten and now they
require explicit scope good news is that
are that you don't need to always say
scope dodge a sync in Cortland you can
you can start when you start a routine
inside another routine so for instance
here we have nested routine the first
one calls the first one is called
the global scope then inside we start a
second one and the second child grew
teen is started in the scope of the
outer core team and this scope of our
two core teen is present in the context
implicitly by this reference and you can
omit this reference and you your started
coaching just look like so you you just
call a sink so in Cortland isn't it the
case that you often call a sink without
the scope however this scope is
implicitly present in the context anyway
so this structure this structural
approach in Cortland is enforced and you
just can't start curtains every way you
can use the global scope to start
Cortese but there a commanded way to do
it is to always use scope if your
application has some objects with a
lifecycle
then you can create a scope specific
attach to this object just inside the
subject and start all the proteins
inside the scope there all the nested
coroutines considered to this object and
then when their object else then all the
crew teens will be automatically
cancelled so that is quite convenient
this recommended practice but in general
huge' you can decide which scopes you
have and at start new crew teens from
the scope and everything then will be
covered automatically nothing really so
this is something new something probably
that will be available in some
frameworks and libraries and probably
ease of already available but in code
length there is this built-in support
for a structure between different
proteins that works via scopes and this
is called structured concurrency now we
move forward and the next question is
how do how to share information between
different proteins so we have like we
can have many proteins and this I see
some I see
programming under the hood and we
definitely need to somehow communicate
between them and their answer is this
lousing shareable communicating is kind
of I pray in the girl world they always
say share by communicating and because
we have the same core routines in the
language then the answer to this will be
very similar use channels and this
channel story is again it's not called
an invention it's present in many
languages now it's available in c-sharp
as well
it's thrives especially in gold and I
want I will just briefly cover how
channels work with coatings channels are
used for we can think of it as a
synchronization but we better say for
communication between coatings now the
ester instead of sharing mutable state
when we're talking about coroutines we
prefer to say that we they should share
something by communicating with on
another with each other not by having
access to a mutable state so that is a
little bit of my shift you need to get
accustomed to this concept but again
it's something that just how the mortal
world writes this code including go now
code lean and probably some others as
well so now our synchronization
primitives should be replaced with
communication primitives and channel is
this main communication primitive
channel is a very simple thing it is
just an interface that provides a way to
send to it and to receive to it receive
from it and one coroutine can send to it
another can receive from it and
basically it's a it solves the classical
consequence in a problem when you can
have several producers several
coroutines
that can send to the same channel and
several consumer
several countries that can receive from
the from the same channel so there it
can be one producer so many consumers it
can be many producers while consumers
the this that all works via this channel
mechanism the channel have two views as
a channel interface actually extends to
different interface sent channel receive
channel and when you pass a reference to
consumers you pass the same channel as
receive channel and if we when you pass
a reference to producers you will give
them San channel so it's straightforward
all the first-class channels looks very
much like general queue with one
important difference all both this send
and receive channels are defined as
suspend so for instance in c-sharp the
same channels are available but you will
need to work with them via a sync avoid
mechanism so you'll wait you can avoid
for the result of receive and set
encoding because we have suspend
functions both this set and receive
functions can be defined as suspend
functions in the library there are many
different types of channels so for
instance there is an onboard channel you
that can store as many elements as you
want to send to it however in this case
you have a possibility for out of member
exception because no one controls how
many elements or how many things you
want to store in it
there are there is also the buffer
channel that has limited capacity and
when the capacity is achieved all the
following sent calls will suspend
there is the render Food Channel which
have it is a buffer without any capacity
so without a buffer this a channel
without a capacity like
a channel with capacity zero so for NTV
channel the sent coal will always
suspend unless there is the received
call that is already waiting to receive
something we're going to discuss how it
works in a minute next and there is also
this conflated channel we just allows
you to override the elements and receive
the last element that voice that was
added to this channel so it works for
situations when you are interested only
in the last event but not in the whole
history of the res when we are talking
about rendezvous channel this is their
most basic channel without any buffer
and both send and receive calls can
suspend if there is the there is no and
now they called it is already awaiting
further is out we say that H the element
is transferred only when send and
receive notifications meet in time and
this meeting in time is gives this name
of the channel or end of a channel and
now I want to demonstrate to show you
how exactly this rentable channel works
what does this mean this send and
receive calls meet in time in this
channel so let's say we have again
classical consumer producer consumer
problem we have in our case we'll have
one producer that says tasks to a
channel and a couple of consumers that
are ready to receive and process these
tasks accordingly each or all producer
and couple of consumers are different
cortines for simplicity first let's say
that the channel will sent only two
tasks so here we create a channel of the
that stores the element of type tasks
and we start a coroutine producer core
team that will simply send a couple of
tasks to this channel and after that it
will
the channel then in our simple scenario
we'll have two consumers each of them
will just receive one receive one
element from this channel and later
process the elements this process task
function it might be suspension or it
might be just through consuming function
does matter the thing is we need to call
this receive receive call from channel
from co-routine because it is a suspend
function so here we have two consumers
they're just each of them just receives
one task how it works we create a
channel then let's say in our case there
say the first consumer starts first so
this cartoon that receives one element
is started and then it tries to receive
an element from the channel however
there is no sent the channel is
emptiness
nothing was sent read and because of
that this consumer coroutine gets
suspended
so this receive call suspends this
consumer Croteam this curtain gets
suspended and then let's imagine their
consumer corrosion starts and it is
ready to send something to channel it
sends the first task to the channel and
now that moment of friend who happens
sent call meets receive call and the
value is actually passed from consumer
from producer to consumer which awakes
the producer co-routine that receives
the stress and start to process it in
the meantime they're producing routine
sends the second task to the channel and
at first the first consumer is busy
processing the first task so there is no
other receive call and because of that
the producer crew team gets suspended
there is no second receive call from
this channel sent now sent call
suspense the producer crew team now
let's imagine the second consumer comes
struts and it's ready to receive element
from this channel then this moment of
friend River happens and the second task
is passed to the second Channel send and
receive calls meet in time and the
second crew teen the second consumer is
busy gets busy processing the second
task so they just start processing them
in our in my simple case I just had two
tasks tasks but in general case of
course consumer can just sense tasks
whenever they appear and their consumers
or producers and the consumers are ready
to receive tasks and to this case we can
in this case we can just send the
specific number of tasks or in general
case you can just send new tasks to the
channel whenever they appear in producer
you can you don't even need to close it
so you can send whenever something comes
and the consumer the code for consumers
is a bit different now you can now
iterate over all over the channel and
this iteration this iterating of the
channel and the hoot calls receive
method while iterating and what it will
do it it will suspend if nothing is yet
available in the channel and if
something is available it will receive
it and process it so that how this
producer consumer solution works for
many tasks and it is a general primitive
how to communicate how to share
something tasks data between different
coroutines and you see that it
automatically balances the load so
whenever there is there is no available
Purdue consumers the producer will just
as bad so if you have fixed number of
producers and fixed number
consumers this suspension mechanism will
automatically balance the load of this
channel of your of your system of your
application there Bofur channel works
very similarly to how rentable channel
works with the difference that it also
has the buffer so you can store some so
this this channel will be able to store
some elements inside but the general
idea that there the next suspend course
will suspend
if the boot of the buffer is is full is
the same so the send calls will suspend
if the buffer is already full and the
received call will suspend if the
channel is empty so there is no
exceptions there is nothing there is no
null returned is just in case of there
there are no tasks there are no
producers there are no consumers their
counterpart the second part just
suspense so that was all what I wanted
to cover today if you want to learn more
about cotton curtains you can you can
check what what what we have as I've
told you there's there is this basic
support for coroutines
at the language level and everything
else is implemented in the library so we
have a sink of weight implemented in the
library channels implemented the library
also actors also yield as in c-sharp
works under uses the underlying
implementation of qualities it does
users in quality isochrones programming
it has nothing to do with the
synchronous pairing but under the hood
it just uses the same mechanism of
routines and much more and the loss of
staff is and can be implemented in the
library we have if you want to play with
it we have now hands on lap intro to
co-routines the channels that allows you
to to just play a bit without it by
yourself
also there are talks I would recommend
the talks by Romina deserve who's the
main author is main creator of the
library and he has given different talks
about co-routines
different design
and especially interesting that in these
calling qualities in practice here it is
the moment when he says that again
before we did he have structured
concurrence and now we have this
structured concurrency and he shows what
was before and what's what is what what
comes afterward if you want to learn
more about Cortland I can't make sure
the content book which you actually can
look through bro through in this
conference it's available and we
recently recorded their whole course
about Scotland at Coursera it doesn't
cover Curtis yet but it covers all the
others and the book doesn't cover
curtains yet as well but it curls all
the rest cotton so thank you a lot for
bit for being here for listening and
have a nice caught me with coroutines
and I'm ready to answer questions like
can channels of tomato channels
automatically supposed a duplication I'm
not sure about native support but I
don't know I actually don't think I'm
not sure but I don't think they support
a duplication but it's probably it's
already planned I don't I'm not sure I
can answer you question sorry yes no no
it's unless its main UI thread it's not
possible so if you want to thread local
variables there is some mechanism to
attach it to coroutines
but it's like okay there is also a
possibility when you have a specific
that you create a new thread and you say
and you create your custom dispatcher
that says all these credentials run on
this thread yeah in this case it's
possible if it's if you just want to if
you just use the thread from the common
pool then any search will it's a
built-in mechanism and
that will be used context of the user
what do you mean available there is just
the reference that you can pass or what
do you mean always throw it in circle
but in curtains you can coroutines wrap
there like you when you start the
coroutine it automatically have access
to all the everything you said this code
so you can explicitly pass something to
it something to it so it's not that it's
like because they're like under the hood
there lambdas that can capture their the
scope then you can automatically
captures their capture their origins by
the way I think I forgot to mention it
different libraries including spring in
the view is going to already have or
going to publish the native support for
this stuff for co-routines and serpent
functions so I suppose that they will
they'll provide kind of expected way
perspective guidelines how to work with
all this I start to to to how the court
is compared with the deferred with the
word with because in encoding as
deferred these tasks yeah so no no I
I mean the court coroutines also uses
the concepts of deferred so deferred
object is actually reference kind of a
reference to drowning coroutines so we
we also I mean what what is the
comparison when we compare quotes in
subject to how its implemented can't say
for sure there is this some small
overhead that you will need to or do
to stroll all the state of the protein
so for instance here when you suspend
the protein you you straw all the call
stack so there is small overhead for
this but on the other hand is only one
object and there are no like in if we
compare for instance with the callbacks
and wear with reactive approach then in
callbacks Niraj reactive approach will
build several lambdas but he only one
object I don't I don't give you an ass
how its compared to like what is exact
overhead in comparison to two to one
call like here if we store default there
is going to be this the whole call stack
like I don't know any benchmarks but as
what I've already heard it works quite
well in terms of performance so I just
can give a very generic answer I'm not
sure I think where is it this way would
be to just to look at their channel
implementation I'm not sure myself
whether it's already available or its
plan to be edit probably I can check any
more questions or so I will answer you
just come to me in a minute yes you can
use colonies when we are talking about
cotton for JVM you can easily use
directive streams Riggs Java it just
works
there it has some a little bit of
additional extensions like Eric Scotland
but it calls Eric Scotland but in fact
it's just a bunch of additional
extractions yes no no there's this regs
Java just is
the library available for Java you can't
mix like cuddling co-routines work and
cutting the suspension functions works
only with courting so it you can't if
you try to call you can't call suspend
functions from Java and it just works
for cotton without coroutines so the
Eric's job is like an independent thing
and in the future we'll have will soon
be relief release some also class that
is similar to reactive stream but that
allows the conversion so they kind of
can be used together but reactive stream
is a bandwidth thing that already works
with Cortland without any support for
coroutines so you can just use both or
decide whether you want for some
specific use case yes runs out of memory
you mean like checking their caching the
case I don't know
this shouldn't be checked so but but I
support my guess is just like crashing
out of memory
yeah but because there is I don't think
there is a mechanism that that
calculates but I haven't heard of
reports like recruited to many
coroutines in comparison to that just
like basically the proteins are the
cheapest person comparison with threads
so there is no problem of creating a lot
of them and I think whilst we still are
in here like we the whole still are in
the face when like mmm now I think it
lasts Google i/o Google announced that
they weren't first-class support for
suspend functions for coroutines and
then all these benchmarks of what can go
wrong in case of - - deep stack and so
on I suppose will follow I haven't read
any guidelines in India in the sense
that don't don't create too deep curtain
so far it seems like every
yeah you have you like you mean whether
you want to do to to observe it somehow
oh no no you you it's I know there's
like it just captures their I suppose
the reference of to the class itself
unless you like and what I measure it if
it captures unless you're using it so
that's also have to be checked like we
can we can check it if you want like I
wouldn't saying like whether it captures
anything that that it doesn't use so
usually how capturing a local variables
works if use this local variables is
captured if it doesn't use it that's you
don't need it yeah so for teens it
should work similarly I'm not sure about
this reference but I my guess it should
be like this so we want to capture
unless you use it yeah but there is
there is some walking progress in terms
of providing the convenient way to debug
everything and to observe what happens
under the hood so recently they added
the support for like indeed elegy when
you debug you can see the stack trace of
of the protein at the moment of
suspension and there are other things
probably already edit or like the other
way to to see what is the current state
like what core scenes we have currently
they currently run the currently
suspended and so on so it's also
possible so I think probably something I
was going on here I'm I'm still here so
if you want we can and I'll be able at
the booth I suppose to earth day and I
have huge cotton stickers so if you're
interested but they again will be the
boots I think